[Musique]
par les enfants bonsoir
j'espère mes petits amis que vous êtes
tous aussi gentil que peppy taille
cornichons c'est un véritable plaisir
pour moi de les retrouver chaque soir
ils sont 6 av
ils ne me font jamais de farce ils sont
merveilleux et je vais vite les voir à
mais cela bien et nous j'y compte bien
et pop pop pop hip hop hop hop hop hop
hop je ne sais pas si je dois vous
laisser faire
nounours ne sera peut-être pas content
[Musique]
tu peux t'en amish taisez vous le voilà
qu harry bonsoir mes ennemis bros
notre ami nous ce qu'ils sont paul on
n'a pas de toit nouveau mars à toi je
crois les faits qu'ils ont bien pensé
avoue que ce gentil que ce que ce
niveau le groupe pour savoir que faire
oui amis ouvrez ouvrons ouvre
aux secours ou ou
ouhlala c'est une souris j'ai toujours
eu
lieu pas comme ça prenez un bon secours
puisque je vous dis que c'était toujours
rien
oui mais oui
[Musique]
enfin chers amis c'est un petit animal
inoffensif
peut-être mais je n'aime pas qu'elle se
promène sur roy à une seconde je vais
lui donner à manger il ne bougera plus
tiers des miettes de pain
à cette main
[Musique]
non mon aîné pas car manger pour la
dernière fois ôter cet animal où je vais
me mettre en colère oh bah alors les
plaisanteries les plus courtes sont
toujours les meilleures pépites à notre
ami décidément n'apprécie pas ces petits
animaux ouf on est fait
merci cher
papa qu'il t'a fait pas dans ce gros
mots ce
qu'est si mignonne là ne fuis pas je te
même chez moi je suis ton ami non pas
aux pauvres nous nous je pensais pas que
tu veux tellement peur des souris où
je n'avais pas réellement peur j'étais
sur vous en effet vous aviez l'air fort
surpris
[Musique]
eh bien merci pour votre surprise
je vous souhaite une bonne année à la
nuit camarades fait de mourir
[Rires]
bonne lune où nous dit tu n'es pas tant
chez moi c'était juste pour rire non je
ne suis pas fâché
dans vite à demain
pour
m
[Musique]
alors nounours vous vous êtes bien amusé
oui pas trop
tu n'as pas l'air très content ils m'ont
fait une farce patron avec une souris
mais je n'ai pas eu peur vous savez
c'est vrai juste un petit peu
aux routes bono midi les enfants allez
vite vous couchant ne fait pas de farce
à nounours embrasser bien fort vos
parents est fait pour eux
[Musique]
vous
hamon
on
[Musique]